[Musik]
großer flüchtlingsgipfel heute in Berlin
selensky bereitet seine Bürger auf die
nächste große Offensive Russlands vor
und auch die coronaaufarbeitung kommt
voran der Brandenburger Landtag will
jetzt in einem
untersuchungsausschussmaßnahmen wie die
Impfpflicht unter die Lupe nehmen es
gibt also viel zu besprechen heute bei
8:15 Uhr mit Julia Neigel Deutschlands
größter Rockstimme die selbst massiv
auch wirtschaftliche unter den
corona-maßnahmen zu leiden hatte und
jetzt eine konsequente Aufarbeitung
fordert mein Kollege Peter Thiede hat
selbst oft aus Russland berichtet kennt
das Land wie weniger andere und sagt wir
dürfen Putin nicht zu ernst nehmen und
auf seiner Angstmacherei hereinfallen
Richter Arne Tank wurde nach seiner
zweiten corona-impfung aus dem Leben
geworfen er hat einen schier
unerträglichen Leidensweg und erzählt
uns hier seine sehr persönliche und sehr
dramatische Geschichte
Landwirt Anthony waren vor schweren
Zeiten für die deutschen Bauern der
immer mehr Auflagen zerstören die
geschäftsgrund Frage und viele
befürchten dass sie ihren Hof nicht mehr
lange halten können wir schaffen es
nicht mehr ja das sagen auch immer mehr
Landräte die nicht mehr wissen wie sie
die steigende Zahl an Flüchtlingen
unterbringen sollen kurz vorm großen
flüchtlingsgipfel heute in Berlin
platzte auch einem grünen Landrat der
Kragen Jens Marco Scherf er sagte
wörtlich bei Markus Lanz im Talk wenn
Integration gelingen soll müssen wir den
Mut haben Missstände ganz offen
anzusprechen er forderte die gesamte
Flüchtlingspolitik zu überdenken führte
eine ganze Liste an Problemen an es
kennen zu viele Flüchtlinge und
Migranten die Kommunen hätten kaum noch
Wohnraum und zu wenig Personal sein
Landkreis Miltenberg in Bayern bräuchte
jede Woche eine neue
Flüchtlingsunterkunft und dass er
einfach nicht zustimmen er selten hatten
grünen Politiker so deutlich Klartext
gesprochen beim Thema Migration prompt
bekamer Schafe Kritik auch aus den
eigenen Reihen Parteikollegen legten ihm
mal die Grünen zu verlassen hier schlägt
also ein grüner landraum Landrat Alarm
was sagt das besser über die aktuelle
flüchtlingskrise und wie wir damit
umgehen eigentlich aus also wer an der
Basis arbeitet der begegnet ja da
Wirklichkeit und wer in einer Blase
arbeitet der begegner grenzt die
Wirklichkeit aus und wir sehen es ja
nicht nur bei diesem Landrat sondern
vorher schon bei Boris Palmer und bei
anderen Grünen auch die die an der Basis
arbeiten die die täglichen Probleme
haben die damit umgehen müssen die
sprechen Klartext und die können auch
nicht mehr und da spielt das Parteibuch
schlichtunter greifen überhaupt gar
keine Rolle wer in den Kommunen und in
den Landratsämtern arbeitet er hat jeden
Tag dieses Problem wir können es nicht
weg diskutieren es lässt sich nicht mit
Ideologie bearbeiten und herzlich
willkommen in der Wirklichkeit dann auch
der großen grünen Blase das sind nicht
nur die Grünen das ist bei der SPD auch
so wir haben es auch in der Union in
Teilen von Union auch in Teilen von der
FDP haben wir dasselbe Problem dass ab
einer bestimmten Ebene Wirklichkeit
einfach ausgeblendet oder verneint wird
und auch mit Navigation das hat man
schon zumindest nicht noch in meiner
komischen Ostschule wo ich noch max und
Leni noch gelernt noch gelernt habe also
als die Elektriker habe ich die ganze
funktioniert nicht also die Wirklichkeit
muss wahrgenommen werden und jetzt
gleichzeitig hier bekommt er von
Parteikollegen nahegelegt er möge sich
mal jetzt freiwillig aus der Partei
verabschieden was sagt das auch aus es
ist so weit gekommen dass man quasi
mundtot gemacht wird wenn man mal
Klartext spricht und das mal ganz
überspitzt zu sagen ja das wird Dir
sicherlich heute auch Thema sein zum
Thema Corona wir haben es den letzten
Jahren gesehen wer immer Klartext redet
und der Tiger hat recht ich bin selbst
Kommunalpolitiker da ist man ganz
schnell in der Schublade oder als
Schwuler ja
verbrannt kann man nicht anders sagen
und ich finde es ich finde schon
abenteuerlich dass das die Grünen ähm
aber sehr vollkommen recht das ist bei
jeder Partei eigentlich momentan so wäre
Klartext spricht und in der Basis
arbeitet der weiß was los ist und das
kommt hier in der Blase in Berlin aber
auch in landshagen anscheinend nicht an
und nicht aber irgendwie verlernt Frau
Neigel ganz sachlich über die sachlichen
Themen miteinander zu diskutieren wird
es gleich persönlich wird es gleich ein
Angriff sowie auch da also ob ich ob wir
das allgemein verlernt haben das mag ich
nicht beurteilen ich denke wir können
das jederzeit wieder aufleben lassen
aber die Situation die durch die
corona-politik stattgefunden hat da
wurde auch seitens der Politik der
führenden Politik sehr häufig mit
dialektischer eristik argumentiert das
bedeutet es ging immer sofort unter die
Gürtellinie also wenn irgendjemand eine
angemessene und konstruktive Kritik
geäußert das habe ich ganz oft erlebt
mit sachlichen Argumenten und man konnte
dem Argument nichts entgegensetzen dann
wurde sofort persönlich argumentiert man
wurde die Familie die Menschen wurden
diskriminiert das haben wir ja ganz oft
erlebt dass jetzt im Nachhinein auch es
heißt ja dieser Kritiker hat eigentlich
Dinge vorausgesehen oder auch vor etwas
gewarnt was heute realistisch gesehen
fakt ist und äh Flüchtlings äh
Diskussion haben Sie den Eindruck da
verläuft das ähnlich oder haben sie da
die Hoffnung dass wir das sachlich ich
habe das also ich habe so und so immer
die Hoffnung dass wir da zurückkehren
auf die sachliche Ebene wie jedes Jahr
und jahrzehntelang gekannt haben denn
das war eigentlich unsere ganz normale
offene Disco ist Kultur und ich denke es
liegt an uns an der Gesellschaft denn
auch die Politiker die das eingeführt
hatten denen es dann natürlich auch
leichter viel gewisse rigide Maßnahmen
durchzusetzen den müssen wir es
abgewöhnen ich denke wir Ihnen innerhalb
der Gesellschaft können es eigentlich
leichter stemmen weil wir natürlich auch
friedlich miteinander diskutieren wollen
merken Sie auch bei in ihrer Heimat des
Kommunen zum Teil überlastet sind das
ist ein Problem
Ludwigshafen und da ist es zum Beispiel
ganz offenkundig und auch in Mannheim
dass das also die die Kommunen
überlastet sind dass man auch praktisch
kaum noch weiß wo man sie alle
unterbringen soll und dann sehen Sie das
so im Alltag ist im Alltag ich sehe
natürlich auch Gruppierungen von von
Menschen von denen man offenkundig sieht
die kommen jetzt frisch hierher die sind
nicht gewohnt hier hier ansässig zu sein
sprechen vielleicht auch ein gar kein
Deutsch im Moment aber das ist
eigentlich der weniger das wenigere
Problem das geringere Problem das
größere Problem ist die Masse es geht
eher um die Masse und ich habe auch
gelesen das ist tatsächlich sogar um
Diskussionen ging dass man bestimmten
Hausbesitzern die Häuser enteignen oder
wegnehmen möchte um die zu befüllen mit
Flüchtlingen ich finde es geht einfach
zu weit sie kam ja selbst als Kind in
ein fremdes Land wie haben sie das
erlebt wird auch einfach zu wenig
geholfen also um das auch mal von der
anderen Seite zu beobachten sind ja auch
Menschen die alleine gelassen werden die
auch nicht wissen wohin mit sich in
großer Not sie meinen jetzt die
Flüchtlinge die kommen also ich kann die
Situation die wir damals hatten nicht
mich jetzt vergleichen wir sind aus wir
sind nach dem kriegsverschleppten Gesetz
hierher gekommen aus der UdSSR nach
Deutschland den 70ern wir hatten wir
haben weniger Hilfe gekriegt als man
sich das vorstellen kann jeder von uns
musste selbstständig Deutschland sich
selbstständig integrieren und von Geld
oder irgendwelchen anderen Dingen war da
gar nicht die Reden
ich persönlich habe mich darüber nicht
geklappt ich bin sehr dankbar dafür dass
wir in unsere Heimat in dem Falle zurück
durften und ich ich glaube das ist halt
für jedes Land einfach Grenzen der Masse
gibt es geht mich darum humanitäre Hilfe
zu leisten das ist notwendig aber es
geht einfach um die Masse und es geht
vor allen Dingen um vernünftige
Maßnahmen und vernünftige Politik und
Angemessenheit sie sind Richter geht es
ihnen so dass sie eine sachliche
Diskussion vermissen wir gehen gleich
ganz tief rein in ihrer auch sehr
persönliche Geschichte aber einmal noch
um an diesem Thema dran zu bleiben wenn
wir das verlernt dass wir da über die
Sachthemen diskutieren den Finger auch
mal in die Wunder halten auch mal das
aufzeigen was nicht funktioniert ohne
dass gleich beispielsweise damit gedroht
wird man soll die Partei verlassen
besser naja also wenn ich meine Arbeit
mache wird natürlich sachlich diskutiert
weil dann ja ein Fall 60 zu bewerten ist
wenn man das nicht sagt ich machen würde
würde die Arbeit schlecht gemacht werden
von daher ist das natürlich schon sehr
sachlich
wir kommen jetzt direkt zu ihrer
Geschichte denn sie gehen in die
Öffentlichkeit sie wollen ein Thema
diskutieren das sehr sehr persönlich ist
auch wahrscheinlich nämlich an um
anderen zu helfen und zu erzählen wie es
ihnen gegen sie haben eine ganz
persönliche dramatische
Leidensgeschichte hinter sich und dieser
Weg der begann für sie nach der zweiten
corona-impfung nehmen Sie uns einmal mit
unbedingt
ich habe mich im Jahr 2021 zweimal
impfen lassen das war nicht mein Wunsch
sondern es war von meinem diensthandwerk
wünscht er uns auch die die Impftermine
besorgt hatte also quasi dafür gesorgt
hat dass wir uns alle geimpft haben und
ein halbes Jahr nach der zweiten Impfung
habe ich dann immer später
diagnostiziert hat eine
Herzmuskelentzündung bekommen das ist
eine typische Nebenfolge der Profit 19
Impfung dann habe ich wieder ein halbes
Jahr später eine Thrombose bekommen
Folgen der Impfung dann im Oktober ein
Schlaganfall hervorgerufen durch zomben
beides sind auch typische
Nebenwirkung oder Folgen der Kubik 19
Impfung und dann sind die Topen auch ins
Herz gewandert und haben bei mir die
Herzkranzgefäße zerstört so dass ich
fünf Stents bekommen musste und auch
noch ein Herzinfarkt habe also jede
Menge schwerwiegende Erkrankungen die
auch zum Tode hätten führen können von
daher bin ich also nicht beklage ich
nicht meine Schicksal dass ich das alles
hatte sondern ich freue mich dass ich
immer noch lebe und das ist ein Wunder
muss man sagen wenn man diese Befreiung
hört dass Sie heute hier sitzen daher
wichtig wie geht es Ihnen heute sie war
natürlich lange arbeitsunfähig konnten
nicht arbeiten jetzt haben sie glaube
ich es vor kurzem auch wieder angefangen
diese Woche wieder zurück in den Job als
Richter wie geht es Ihnen heute sehr
viel besser also das
dramatischste was ich hatte war bei dem
Schlaganfall wobei ich da auch Glück
hatte ich habe also keine körperlichen
Einschränkungen bekommen keine
Sprachstörung aber ich hatte
vorübergehenden völligen Verlustes
Gleichgewichts das wusste also nicht wo
oben unten rechts links war da können
sie sich nicht auf den beinhalten da
gehen sie unten weiter nicht zu Boden so
ist mir das auch klar geworden da hatte
ich gerade eine mündliche Verhandlung
gehabt und auf dem Weg zu meinem
Büro haben meine Beine versagt und ich
lag dann auf dem Boden und musste dann
sehen wie ich dann meinen beruflichen
konnte was mir noch genommen weil ich
habe das auch für die falsche
eingeschätzt ich dachte deswegen
irgendwelche Kreislaufstörungen jemand
hat das so ernst genommen das ist dann
ist ein paar Tage später diagnostiziert
worden dass das ein Schlaganfall war
wir haben sie sich aufgehoben und
geholfen gefühlt wir haben sie auch den
Zusammenhang hergestellt mit Hilfe von
Ärzten das muss von der Impfung
irgendwie gekommen sein es gibt immer
mehr Medien die auch jetzt darüber
berichten dass es im Schäden gibt es
gibt Menschen die darum kämpfen dass
diese auch als solche anerkannt werden
das ist aber für viele die das Annehmen
ein schwieriger Weg und es ist vor allem
ja auch schwer diesen Zusammenhang
medizinisch darzustellen wie war das für
Sie genau das habe ich jetzt auch noch
nicht bekommen also dass das im Schäden
sind steht nicht in dass du das
tierischer Sicht fest dass sie nicht
bewiesen es ist nur sehr sehr
wahrscheinlich überwiegend
wahrscheinlich bin es auch gerade erst
vor wenigen Tagen aus der Rehaklinik
entlassen worden also noch keine
Gelegenheit mich darum zu kümmern dass
feststellen zu lassen aber ich muss
weiterhin auch damit leben dass man das
nicht wahrhaben will dass das bei mir da
liegen kann nach dem Motto das kann ja
gar nicht sein und gerade so viele
Folgen das ist ja unwahrscheinlich und
das hast du dir doch alles nur
ausgedacht also so mit solchen
konfrontiert natürlich
selbst so sicher dass sie sagen dass das
war die eben typische Sachen und auch
verschiedene also auch die
Herzmuskelentzündung die ich zu dir hat
ja eigentlich nichts mit der mit den
ganzen anderen Sachen zu tun durch die
durch trocken gekommen sind ist aber die
häufigste
Nebenfolge und das sind eben Sachen die
ich habe also keinerlei Indikationen für
all diese Sachen hier in meiner Familie
gibt's nichts in meiner Lebensgeschichte
gibt es nicht die einzige Indikation
genau die war vorher immer gesagt der
einzige Indikation die man feststellen
kann die das ausgelöst haben kann ist
eben die Impfung ansonsten würde man
sagen ich habe eben unwahrscheinliches
Pech gehabt nur so viel Pech das fand
ich für eher unwahrscheinlich haben Sie
das Gefühl ihn wird da jetzt auf diesem
Weg Zusammenhänge herzustellen ihre
eigene Krankheitsgeschichte
aufzuarbeiten viel geholfen oder wird
das eher geblockt damit man nicht
geholfen das muss ich sicherlich alles
sind Unternehmen wie fühlt sich das für
Sie an
auf sich alleine geschätzt sie haben
eine ziemlich dramatische Geschichte wir
haben gerade gesagt ein Wunder dass sie
hier sitzen wenn Sie alles aufzählen da
würde ja eine Sache reichen für einen
Menschenleben gefallen wenn man daraus
den Schluss ziehen würde dass der die
Behauptung die Impfung sei ungefährlich
und neben Folgen sein so
unwahrscheinlich dass man das verneinen
kann aufgegeben würde und darauf
hinweisen kann das durchaus damals hatte
ich neben Folgen entstehen kann
unabhängig ist von meinem Fall ob das so
ist aber es gibt ja nachgewiesene Fälle
deswegen weiß ich ja auch dass gerade
diese Kranken die ich erlitten habe
typischerweise auch sind wenn es auch
für einen singen Prozentzahl ist aber es
ist eben deutlich mehr als 0 also es
gibt diese Nebenwirkungen und es wird
doch immer aus der Politik vor allem
verkauft das geht gegen Null das kann
man völlig danach lesen Sie das Gefühl
sie wurden genug aufgeklärt also ich
habe bei meiner Impfung überhaupt nicht
gewusst dass das keine herkömmliche
Impfung ist ich habe mich jahrelang
gegen Influenza impfen lassen dachte
dass wir auch so eine Stoff Impfung wie
es da wäre und dass man mit solch
dramatischen Folgen rechnen kann hat man
mir nicht gedacht war glaube ich damals
auch nicht bekannt das ist ja jetzt im
Nachhinein aufgetaucht war ja diese
ganzen Stoffe ja auch nur vorläufig
zugelassen worden sind ohne den ganzen
Test Zyklus zu durchlaufen das heißt man
kriegt erst nach der Verabreichung der
Impfung mit wir überhaupt die neben
Folgen sind und möglicherweise in meinem
Fall hat also das Gefühl da gibt es
einen ganz starken Zusammenhang zwischen
seiner Krankheitsgeschichte und der
corona-impfung Peter ist das Gefühl dass
Menschen die diese Annahme haben zu sehr
alleine gelassen werden naja muss ein
paar Sachen auseinander das ist ein ganz
dramatisches Schicksal wir kennen alle
keine Mediziner wie wir sitzen wir
wissen nicht ob wir Zusammenhang
tatsächlich dahin als Richter nicht
erzählen
da ist Forschung notwendig die ist da
die ist meine Sachen nicht ausreichend
es ist auch die Betreuung durch Ärzte
oder die Information auch der Ärzte ist
nicht genügend wenn man dann auf dem
Land wohnt und beim normal Landarzt ist
dann gute Nacht Marie weil die sind in
der Regel nicht richtig aufgeklärt also
da kommt ganz viel auf dem Hausarzt
drauf an und auf die Krankenkassen wir
müssen aber aufpassen dass er nicht
schon so tun als als sei immer gesagt
worden dass sie komplett
nebenwirkungsfrei sind das ist nicht
nein das ist nie gesagt und dass die
komplett nebenwirkungsfrei sind nein
also Lauterbach hat das gesagt da gab es
eine Klage deswegen also ganz klar
getwittert das Arzneimittel sein
nebenwirkungsfrei das stimmt das war ein
Riesenskandal also der damals zuständige
Gesundheitsminister hieß nicht lauter
macht sondern sparen und ich glaube
nicht dass sie einen Satz von ihm damals
zuständigen Gesundheitsminister Spanien
finden der sehr sagt dass diese Mittel
nebenwirkungsfrei sind sondern in allen
in allen in allen Publikationen stand
drinne das ist Nebenwirkungen haben kann
es gibt eine Dokumentation übernehmen
Wirkung dass die Mittel dann haben sie
völlig Recht die waren vorläufig
zugelassen das ging damals auch nicht
anders weil schlicht und ergreifend der
erprobungszeitraum sonst noch ein paar
Jahre gedauert hätte sonst wäre das so
wie es damals war so dramatisch
weitergegangen und ich kann sagen ich
war vor bevor sie Prüfung gab lag ich
mit covid im Krankenhaus so ein Stück
vor der Intensivstation dass sie nicht
auf den auf der Intensivstation lag hat
nur damit zu tun dass ich vorher bei
einer guten Ärztin war meine Hausärztin
hat mich vorher nicht betreut ich bin
dann von Kollegen meiner Frau zu einer
infektiologin dann geschickt worden und
so eine immunologin die so versiert war
dass ich als ich ins Krankenhaus kam
schon alle Werte die man innerhalb der
nächsten drei Tage hätte erheben müssen
schon da waren und dadurch hat man mich
quasi vor der Intensivstation noch
gerettet aber das war niemand hat gesagt
dass sie nebenwirkungsfrei sind es ist
ein dramatischer Fall und ich will ihn
auch nicht absprechen das ist das von
den Punkt das ist von der Impfung kommen
kann aber wir müssen aufpassen dass sie
nicht so tun als sei das ein
Massenphänomen als sein die meisten
Leute die geimpft worden sind krank
geworden es gibt dramatische Folgen da
ist Forschung wirklich notwendig da ist
auch eine bessere Betreuung bin ich voll
die völlig bei ihm nur nötig da muss
auch geguckt werden ob man da unter
Umständen dann entschädigen muss aber es
ist nicht das Massenphänomen es ist nie
gesagt und das ist nebenwirkungsfrei ist
gleichzeitig sofort gleichzeitig auf die
Impfkampagne natürlich trotzdem weiter
wie stehen Sie dazu im siehe das Gefühl
man sollte man kann sich jetzt noch
einfach impfen lassen oder sind doch
Geschichten wie diese etwas die sie zum
Nachdenken anregen finde sie haben das
ja sehr sachlich gerade dargestellt und
niemand hat jetzt gesagt dass das
Massenphänomen ist oder sowas das kann
ja vielleicht noch kommen wissen wir
noch nicht alle ich kenne auch
persönlich Leute wo es sehr
wahrscheinlich ist dass das irgendwie
Nebenwirkung ist und auch Sportler aber
Wahrscheinlichkeit wahrscheinlich habe
ich ja gesagt ich habe nicht gesagt dass
es so ist aber es wurde schon so auch
wenn man es nicht wortwörtlich gesagt
hat der Spanier tatsächlich nicht gesagt
aber es wurde schon so gerührt dass sei
alles harmlos machen sie mal alles
überhaupt kein Problem auch man es kommt
darauf an wie es beim Bürger ankommt ich
bin stinken Maler Bürger ich gucke dass
ich höre das und dann hat man schon das
Phänomen gehabt oder das war so
wahrgenommen gerade passiert nehmen wir
uns frei man muss das nicht aussprechen
Politik hat aber da an Glaubwürdigkeit
verloren das ist einfach nur
Unterstellung zu sagen dass die Politik
mit Absicht suggeriert das habe ich doch
gar nicht gesagt
wurde gesagt impfen machen suche ich
Kinder impfen ganz ehrlich wie viele
kenne ich diese ihre Kinder geimpft
haben wo ich gesagt habe mein Gott das
kannst du nicht machen sie sind mir doch
sicherlich einer Meinung das ist oder
soweit ich weiß ja na klar aber gar
nicht sehr oft darum geht was haben die
Politiker gesagt was haben sie gesagt
und da schauen wir jetzt einmal rein
ich weiß noch passieren muss bis
wirklich der letzte versteht dass diese
Impfung einen selbst zuerst einmal
schützt aber eben vor allem auch für uns
alle als Gesellschaft
dann auch Sicherheit gibt insofern sehe
ich eine unbedingte moralische
Verpflichtung sich impfen zu lassen wenn
wir uns für alle weigern würden die gut
erforschte und nebenwirkungsarme Impfung
zu nutzen um uns selbst und andere
phototisch schwere Krankheit zu schützen
würden wir die Pandemie wahrscheinlich
nie beenden können weltweit sind
Hunderte von Millionen Menschen mit den
modernen Impfstoffen geimpft es sind es
eine erhebliche Zeit verstrichen und
deshalb können wir heute wirklich sagen
die Impfstoffe sind sehr sicher und sehr
wirksam und trotzdem haben wir noch 15
Millionen Erwachsene in Deutschland die
das impfangebot offenbar nicht
wahrnehmen wollen
so haben wir also reingehört jetzt
können wir hier mit diesen Informationen
am Tisch auch arbeiten und ich habe das
Gefühl dass jedem etwas auf den Lippen
legt jeder jetzt gerne der erste sein
möchte der hat Informationen
also sie haben jetzt drei drei Personen
gezeigt also der Herr Spahn zum Beispiel
hat immer behauptet das ist jetzt hier
nicht gezeigt worden es ist eine
ordentliche Zulassung der EU nein es war
eine bedingte Zulassung der EU mit der
Maßgabe ist eine gibt bestimmte
Verordnung 507.2016 in der man im
zehnten bewegungsgrundsatz darauf
hingewiesen hat dass das
Gesundheitswesen so wie das die gesamte
Bevölkerung darüber aufgeklärt werden
muss dass man keine Nebenwirkungen noch
nicht kennen kann weil eben die Studien
und die klinische und zwar also die
zweite dritte klinische Studie durch die
immer noch bis Dezember 2023 noch laufen
wird erstens trotzdem hat er gesagt es
wäre eine ordentliche Zulassung der EU
zweitens Helge Braun hat in Mannheimer
immer Morgenmagazin erwähnt
ich leider jetzt nicht hier gezeigt
worden es wäre eine sterile Immunität
die es auslöst und das wissen wir er ist
Mediziner und wir wissen ganz genau es
löst keinen fremdschutz aus es löst
keine sterile Immunität aus im Gegenteil
das heißt er war Mediziner und er sprach
davon das wissen wir ich kenne keine
einzige Studie in der man davon gewusst
hätte weil es nicht immer gegenteilig
behauptet wurde Herr Lauterbach hat auf
Zwitter behauptet es wäre
nebenwirkungsfrei da gab es tatsächlich
eine Klage in diesem Falle wurde dann
eben vom Gericht gesagt es wäre
Meinungsfreiheit was ich nicht
nachvollziehen kann weil er hat es
nämlich als Gesundheitsminister gesagt
und das halte ich für unwahre
unverantwortlich es war nie
nebenwirkungsfrei es gibt gar kein
Arzneimittel das nebenwirkungsfrei ist
und was die Masse der möglichen im
Schäden betrifft sind wir noch ganz ganz
ganz am Anfang es gibt eine immer
Datenbank da sind wir bei ich glaube
zwei Millionen Verdachtsfällen
mittlerweile und Verdachtsfälle von
40.000 Toten
es nagelt mich nicht fest das sind auf
jeden Fall schon die die Größe einer
Stadt und die klinischen Studien sind
nicht beendet also die zweite dritte
klinische Studie läuft noch und erst
danach kann man überhaupt beurteilen ob
langfristig Nebenwirkungen und Schäden
erzeugt werden können das heißt wir sind
ganz am Anfang dieser ganzen Methoden
und dass man eben eine bedingte
Zulassung erteilt hat ohne die Menschen
darüber zu informieren halte ich muss
wirklich hart widersprechen ich habe
Jens Spahn in der während der Corona
Zeit und er zu dumm die Impfstoffe gegen
und auch um die Zulassung die Impfstoffe
geht mehrfach interviewt das ist auch
nachlesbar und nachschaubar die
entspannt hat nie nicht erwähnt das ist
eine bedingte Zulassung ist dass das
immer Beton er hat es niemals also
vielleicht aber ganz gut also das geht
so nicht wenn ich sage ich habe ihm
gesprochen und er hat mir gesagt dann
können sie nicht einfach sagen das hat
nicht stattgefunden so kann man nicht
diskutieren was sie mit ihm geredet
haben ich kann nur sagen was die Videos
zu finden ist im Internet da gibt
jeder gegenüber einem 16-jährigen
Mädchen übers Mikrofon vor ungefähr 100
Leuten wohl klar gesagt hat es ist eine
ordentliche Zulassung
es ist eine ordentliche Zulassung und
bei diesen wahlkampfgespräch ordentliche
Zulassungen
lassen Sie mich bitte mal ausreden
Dankeschön in diesem wahlkampfgespräch
das war 2021 kurz vorm Herbst hat er
rumgedruckst und drum gedruckt bis diese
16-jährige Mädchen ihm wirklich aus dem
Mund gequetscht hat dass er zugeben
musste es ist eine bedingte Zulassung
waren sie das Interview gehabt haben
doch gar nicht anders möglich gewesen
der Zeitraum hat nichts anderes
zugelassen als aus ihrer Logik heraus
aber
die Gespräche durchsehen also alles was
er in der Öffentlichkeit gesagt hat bis
2021 im September habe ich nicht einmal
gelesen dass er von einer bedingten
Zulassung gesprochen ich habe einen
anderen problematischen Punkt eben bei
den Zitaten und da bin ich ja auch
wieder auf ihre Linie das ist der
moralischen Druck der aufgebaut worden
ist
so da zu sagen es besteht eine
moralische Verantwortung dafür sind
Politiker schlicht und ergreifend nicht
zuständig die sind für Recht und Gesetz
zuständig sind dafür zuständig dass
bestimmte Sachen den Regeln entsprechend
durchgeführt werden das hinterher
vielleicht wenn es dann schwierig im
Stehen gibt dass das erforscht wird dass
das dann auch Hilfen bereitgestellt
werden dafür sind Politiker zuständig
aber nicht dafür aber nicht dafür uns
moralischen Kompass zu geben da bin ich
dahin bei einem anderen Musik muss ich
wirklich sagen vorsicht
es geht aufgrund des Zeitraumes wäre
eine andere Zulassung überhaupt nicht
möglich gewesen als eine beliebte weil
nämlich die studienzeiträume viel viel
länger sind dann hätten wir heute
vielleicht jetzt mal die erste Impfung
also das mag ja alles so sein aber dann
muss man die Menschen darüber
informieren also
immer zum zum Bild lesen weil in der
Bild was genau erklärt was ist was ist
eine bedingte Zulassung
war im Februar 2021 gestanden wenn du
geimpft bist bist
weiter kommen ich glaube es gab eine
Einigung bei dem Punkt
das ist eine zumindest moralische
Verpflichtung gab die suggeriert wurde
mehr möchte ich da gar nicht dafür ich
möchte von Herrn Tank noch einmal
abholen wie es bei Ihnen jetzt
weitergeht sie haben hier gerade ihren
Weg geschildert sie sind jetzt wieder
frisch zurück im Job nach all der
Leidensgeschichte man konnte kaum mit
zehn Herzinfarkt Schlaganfall Stent
gesetzt also da haben sie wirklich was
hinter sich jetzt sind sie frisch im Job
was würde Ihnen helfen was sind ihre
Erwartungen was fordern sie denn jetzt
ich möchte natürlich irgendwann nicht
mehr sagen müssen es spricht
überwiegendes dafür nicht würde er immer
gerne sagen müssen es steht fest das ist
ein entscheiden
ist das müsste man natürlich irgendwann
rausfinden und wenn man eben zum
Ergebnis kommen sollte dass nachweisbar
ist das ist ein im Schaden ist das ähm
mir natürlich dann auch geholfen mit
dauerhaft gesund zu werden also jetzt
sind wir auf dem stand dass ich Ende des
Jahres noch mal einen Termin bekommen um
das dauerhaft zu beheben weil bis jetzt
bekomme ich
blutende Mittel um
die tortenbildung zu verhindern um
erstmal auf der sicheren Seite zu sein
sonst würde ich wahrscheinlich jede
Woche ein Herz und Farbraum aus welchem
Grund auch immer und das gilt es
natürlich dann zu vermeiden sonst muss
ich mich jetzt mal zu Recht finden also
ich darf noch nicht wieder 100% arbeiten
das muss ich meinen ersten versprechen
dass ich mich erstmal noch zurück halte
und dann jetzt wieder ins Leben zurück
wenn ich bin ja schon froh dass ich
jetzt nicht mehr in einer Klinik bin
sondern wieder am Berufsleben teilnehmen
kann und auch wieder an meinem
allgemeinen Leben teilnehmen kann
vielleicht für ihre Gewohnheiten auch
wieder aufgreifen kann die jetzt die
letzten Monate natürlich verschwunden
sind dabei wünschen wir Ihnen natürlich
ganz viel Kraft dass sie einfach auch in
das alte Leben wieder richtig zurück
finden noch letzte Frage an Sie wie
fühlen sie sich es wird dir jetzt ein
bisschen auch zurückgerudert es gibt
hier und damals sehen eine
Entschuldigung wie wirkt das dann noch
das finde ich natürlich gut dass
inzwischen das nicht totgeschrieben wird
sondern dass man auch in sogenannten
Medien der ist aus dem Bereich auch die
Zeit um die 31
ist offen auch über im Opfer und im
Schäden gesprochen wird oder den
Verdacht jedenfalls ich finde es schon
gut dass das nicht unter den Teppich
gekehrt wird sondern man das ganze auch
anspricht und egal ob man nun gesagt hat
das sei impf Folgen frei oder auch nicht
so eine solche dramatischen Folgen sind
natürlich so nicht klar gemacht worden
und das wäre natürlich gut wenn man also
auch klar stellt das ist gute Gründe
gibt sich nicht irgendein zu lassen wenn
man das ganze abwägt wie ist das Risiko
ist
beschrieben auch man kann sehr sehr
ähnliche Folgen davon haben und wo wir
19 zu erkannten man kann aber auch wie
man ja inzwischen weiß sehr erhebliche
Folgen haben wenn man sich impfen lässt
das muss also jeder abwägen wenn man
dann moralischen Druck erzeugt der dann
bei jedem einzelnen dazu führt zu sagen
ich blende mal meine Person völlig aus
ich Opfer mich für die Allgemeinheit auf
ist das vielleicht auf Dauer nicht der
richtige Weg
und das sagen ja auch sie Frau Neigel
für sie ist klar man hätte es sehr früh
schon sehr viel besser wissen müssen und
sie fordern da muss jetzt eine wirkliche
Aufklärung an da sind wir mittendrin in
ihrem Thema ist ihre Zeit ihre Kamera
gut also ich bin da Auffassung ist
genügt nicht dass einige Politiker
zurückrudern oder sich nur einfach in
irgendeiner Art und Weise für einige
Teile der corona-politik zum Beispiel
Kita Schließung oder Schulschließungen
entschuldigen ich halte es finden
wesentlich und wichtig dass es eine
politische eine mediale und auch eine
juristische Aufarbeitung gibt um auch
die Gesellschaft und deren Spaltung und
diese ganzen Diskriminierung die
stattgefunden haben auch zu haben es
braucht eine gesellschaftliche und
politische und juristische Gerechtigkeit
das ist der eine Punkt in Florida z.B
wird jetzt die Pharmaindustrie in dem
Fall soweit ich weiß Pfizer und moderner
verklagt in Washington hat man jetzt an
den Untersuchungsausschuss eingeleitet
um die Dinge aufzuarbeiten weil man eben
auch die Verknüpfung zwischen
politischen Interessen und Konzern
Interessen aufarbeiten möchte und ich
dass wir wesentlich es auch hier in
Deutschland zu tun es gibt zum Beispiel
solche Themen also natürlich spricht man
jetzt zum Beispiel über die die schweren
Folgen für Kinder aber es gibt zum
Beispiel auch die Situation in
Seniorenheimen in Kliniken in denen man
besuchsverbote erteilt hat obwohl das
nach Paragraph 28a absatz 2 Satz 2
Infektionsschutzgesetz sogar im Gesetz
stehend formell gesetzlich verboten war
es gibt die mittelbare Impfpflicht die
durch 2G entstanden ist die jetzt zum
Beispiel Lichtenstein als
verfassungswidrig erklärt wurde es gibt
die versammlungsverbote die man gemacht
hat und zwar im kleineren und großen
Maße sei es Demonstrationen sei es
Konzerte die man zum Beispiel im
Straßburger Menschen Gerichtshof als
menschenrechtswidrig erklärt hat es gab
Kultur lockdowns die wir abgekriegt
haben als Künstler die jetzt zum
Beispiel im österreichischen
Verfassungsgericht zumindest beim
dritten Lockdown als verfassungswidrig
erklärt wurden und es gibt natürlich
auch so Dinge wie die fehlende
Aufklärung das ist zum Beispiel eine
bedingte Zulassung ist dass man
bestimmte nebenwir noch gar nicht
einschätzen kann das ist ein
gentechnisches Therapeutikum ist und das
ist eine bedingte Zulassung ist die so
niemals kommuniziert wurden jedenfalls
nicht in der Form das ist die
Allgemeinheit wenn man jetzt kein Arzt
ist oder Journalist wie sie in der Form
hätte verstehen können und ich finde es
ist extrem wichtig dass wir im Bundestag
einen unabhängigen neutralen
Untersuchungsausschuss haben und die
Politik der zwei Legislaturperioden die
damit einhergeht aufarbeiten und
eventuell auch Konsequenzen gezogen
werden
da müssen Rücktritte beispielsweise das
halte ich eigentlich für normal also ich
komme ich bin schon etwas länger auf der
Welt und früher haben ganz andere Dinge
gereicht und Rücktritte zu erzeugen ich
kenne das 12 Selbstmord oder aus meiner
Branche die einfach mal kurz passiert
sind weil man gesagt hat alle müssen
jetzt sofort irgendwie nicht mehr
arbeiten dürfen nicht mehr arbeiten
Tätigkeitsverbot für uns was
Berufsverbot ja aber zum Beispiel mehr
Bundesländern gab es neun Monate gar
kein Geld oder sieben Monate wie jetzt
zum Beispiel in Rheinland-Pfalz ja da
sind dann Existenzen ruiniert worden und
wir haben jetzt natürlich zum Beispiel
clubssterben wir haben kultursterben wir
haben eine Gesellschaft die gewohnt ist
auf dem Sofa zu sitzen und Netflix
zuschauen
dass sich die Konzertsäle nicht füllen
dass ich die Branche gar nicht richtig
wieder auf die Beine kommt naja es ist
halt es ist halt so dass es publiziert
wurde also Kultur ist nicht
systemrelevant ist sie nicht nach dem
Sozialpakt an der fünf ist die
kulturelle Teilhabe extrem wichtig auch
für die Gesellschaft also da sein
Fürsorge die gehört zum Menschenrecht
dazu und wenn man den Menschen gegenüber
suggeriert ihr könnt euch die kulturelle
Teilhabe irgendwie beim Fernsehen oder
im Streaming abholen und man braucht gar
nicht mehr zum Konzert zu gehen das sind
völlig anderes Erlebnis dann spürt man
das schon also wir haben jetzt zum
Beispiel Patricia Kelly hat eine Tour
absagen müssen weil sie gesagt hat und
die Frau ist sehr erfolgreich
sie kann es nicht stimmen sie kann die
Tournee nicht ständig Leute haben
entweder
noch nicht geschafft sich wieder daran
zu gewöhnen in die Menge zu gehen oder
sie sind immer noch daran gewöhnt mehr
zu Hause zu bleiben und wie gesagt
bleibt zu Hause seid ihr Helden das muss
man den Menschen eigentlich wieder
klarmachen es ist vorbei kommt wieder in
die Konzerte kultur ist ein wesentlicher
Faktor für eine Demokratie und vor allen
Dingen für ein gesundes
gesellschaftliches Gesamtbild haben Sie
das Gefühl dass die gesamte Gesellschaft
noch sehr darunter leidet noch sehr
unter der Pandemie und ihren Folgen
leider absolut das sieht man ich bin
britischer Staatsbürger auch also ich
habe gesehen am 19.07 21 war in UK alles
vorbei da ging das Leben normal weiter
wo wir hier noch teilweise im Lockdown
saßen und ähm die sind da ganz anders
mit umgegangen auch in Holland wir haben
bei uns auf dem Hof wo ich herkomme noch
ein kleines Hotel und die Gäste die aus
dem Ausland zu uns kamen die haben uns
immer angeguckt mit großen Augen was
macht ihr hier und das war so also das
was nein gesagt hat wir müssen aus
diesem zugegebenen Fehlern die wir jetzt
dazugeben dringend lernen wenn ich aber
Frau laserhöre ich war mal bis 2010 hier
bei der Polizei in Berlin tätig wenn ich
dann höre wir können unser
demokratisches Recht auf Versammlung von
zu Hause wahrnehmen dann spricht das
Bände ganz ehrlich also wir müssen
irgendwann auch zur Normalität
zurückkommen wir müssen uns auch offen
und hier auch mal ein bisschen Klartext
reden das geht und danach in die Augen
gucken können und sagen ist in Ordnung
das müssen wir wieder lernen streiten
gesund streiten wo wir eingangs drüber
gesprochen haben respektvoll sonst sonst
wird die Gesellschaft gar nicht heilen
ist hier am Tisch vielen ist ein
Entschuldigung ein Zurück äh Rudern ein
Fehler einsehen einfach nicht genug
braucht es da mehr Aufarbeitung seitens
der Politik geht die nicht weit genug in
deinen Augen also wir müssen ein paar
Sachen auseinander pullen da sind jetzt
ganz viele Katzen in einem Sack drinne
die müssen immer nacheinander rausnehmen
also die ganz viele Entscheidungen haben
sich als dann im Nachhinein als falsch
herausgestellt da gehört es zum guten
Ton dass man sich dafür entschuldigt
oder dass man es zumindest sagt dass man
Fehler
von diesen Entscheidungen sind ganz
viele nicht bewusst gegen Leute gemacht
worden sondern es gab einen anderen
Impetus das war in der ersten Phase wo
man nicht wusste was tatsächlich los und
ich rede jetzt nur von der ersten Phase
ich rede nicht von dem ganzen Jahr da
war ganz viel aus Unwissenheit quasi da
ist man in eine Höhle gegangen hat sich
zurückgezogen weil draußen unbekanntes
Raubtier war dann hat dann den Schritt
verpasst wieder rauszugehen man ist
ängstlich drin sitzen geblieben und da
muss man da tatsächlich auch der Politik
einen wirklich kommen konkreten Vorwurf
machen und die Kinder und die Kita
Schließung damals die waren das hat man
zum Teil damals schon gewusst es gab ja
andere Experten die andere Sachen gesagt
haben als sie die damals beteiligt waren
es gab auch Politiker die in einer
anderen Meinung waren zum Beispiel
selbst Karl Lauterbach weil man dagegen
das muss man schlicht und ergreifend
aufarbeiten da bin ich völlig bei auch
völlig bei Frauen bei Frau Neigel das
muss aufgearbeitet werden das gehört
auch zur politischen Hygiene mit dazu
dass man egal aus welchen Gründen man
Entscheidungen getroffen hat ich
unterstelle nicht aus Böswilligkeit aber
wenn die sich im Nachhinein als falsch
herausstellen dann gehört es sich
schlicht und ergreifend und auch um das
in Zukunft zu vermeiden dass man das
überprüft ich möchte nur eins richtig
stellen der der biontech und der
moderner Impfstoff das sind keine
gentechnischen Therapeutikums nein sind
es nicht dumm ist zwischen bei und Check
und dem Gesundheitsminister
ähm Information
ja doch
technisches Therapeutikum
es wird nur aus politischen Gründen nach
der EU als Impfung deklariert weil es
eben in diesem Falle und Corona geht und
Corona ist ein Infektionskrankheit
die wollen uns alle nur irgendwie
täuschen
und ich will auch dem auch dem Eindruck
entgegentreten dass da Konzerne mit der
Politik gemauschelt hätten um Gewinne
wegen da waren tatsächlich Leute dran da
haben ganze ganz Abteilungen Tag und
Nacht gearbeitet über Monate sind
hinterher fast zusammengebrochen ich
unterstelle dann niemanden von vorne
rein eigennutzt alles mögliche dass
damit Geld verdient worden ist ja das
ist so das ist mit anderen Sachen auch
so aber stimmt ihn ja völlig zu dass man
hinterher einfach gucken muss was ist da
was ist da passiert was ist falsch
gelaufen und dann muss es auch
Konsequenzen geben und das geht nicht
dass ich helfe braun einfach
verabschiedet der Mann war damals
Immunität sterile Immunität und das
wissen wir und ich wollte ihnen noch mal
zu dieser gentherapeutischen Sache
also dass sie oh von Bayern von Bayern
der hat 2001 ganz klar gesagt also
hätten wir Corona nicht gehabt würde die
Zell und Gentherapie
gesagt haben
kein gentherapeutikum ist es nicht
genügend Veränderungen
aus dem dezember 2021 da wird es sogar
festgestellt dass es kein gentechnisch
veränderter Impfstoff ist das ist nicht
beurteilen ich bin kein Mediziner aber
es ist ein gentechnisches Therapeutikum
und dazu gibt es mehrere Studien und das
sagen ganz viele Ärzte und
Wissenschaftler
mir geht's nur darum dass der Eindruck
nicht erweckt wird dass er gentechnisch
rum manipuliert worden darum geht es mir
nur wenn wir uns darum gut
sagen dann sind
ob Vorsatz oder nicht ich bin kein
Richter ich bin kein Arzt ich bin
einfach ganz normale BürgerInnen und ich
habe mich viele informiert ich hatte
viel Zeit hatte Berufsverbot und eins
weiß ich zum Beispiel schon etwas länger
Pfeifer hat einen Schadensbericht im
Februar 2021 an die CDC verschickt und
das waren ja auch die die dann praktisch
die Schadensberichte an die immer
schicken mussten Vertrieb und in diesem
aus 21 aus im Februar steht auf Seite 17
covit 19 und schwere Verläufe ist eine
Nebenwirkung dieses Produktes und danach
kommt ab Seite 30 bis Seite 38
unglaubliche unglaubliche Nebenwirkungen
in also aber tödliche
sieht bei jedem so eine Liste
gibt
wenn ich zum Arzt gehen mich impfen
lassen weil meine Frau hat in der Praxis
gearbeitet oder arbeitet in in einer
Praxis die auch im Innern natürlich
kriegst du als Patient oder nicht den
beipackzette zu der Viola aber es gibt
einen Aufklärungsbogen es gibt Ärzte die
aufklären müssen so fast gar nichts drin
und die Beipackzettel wurden entfernt
über eine Verordnung die im Mai 2020 von
Herrn Spahn höchstper
und sich impfen lassen es gibt zu einer
Phiolen nicht sechs beipacken
wie gesagt Aufklärung die med
SVS glaube ich hieß die wurde 2020
viele Fragen die hier an diesem Tisch
wir offen lassen müssen es gibt aber
glaube ich die Einigung darüber dass
Aufklärung mit mehr Transparenz und
genaues Hinschauen bei diesen auch immer
noch wie sie merken hoch emotionalen
Thema ein hier am Tisch wichtig sind wir
schaffen einmal durch wir sind gleich
zurück hier bei 8:15 Uhr bis gleich
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren und zu viertel nach acht wir
haben viel Gesprächsstoff muss das
wirklich sein das ist doch völlig
Realität ich finde diese Debatten
unheimlich wichtig
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht ruinieren ganz richtig was die
Frau Wagner Ich sag ehrlich gesagt ist
das fast totalitäre sie da vorne
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glückler
und Herr Bruder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst das Problem ist nicht
dass wir zu wenig Stadt haben wir haben
zu viel Staaten wenn die alle wegfallen
und wir uns gegenseitig in Berlin Mitte
Cappuccinos verkaufen das funktioniert
nicht dann ist mit Wohlstand das ist
alles essen als freiheitsliebender
Mensch würde ich sagen das muss jedem
erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und Währungen von
Menschen in unserem Land fordert dann
müsst ihr bei euch anfangen da muss doch
was machbar ich finde aber diese gesamte
Debatte die wir auch fühlen auch ein
bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt mit dem Gericht
[Musik]
da sind wir wieder zurück bei 8:15 Uhr
schön dass Sie bei uns sind hier wurde
noch viel diskutiert und jetzt geht es
um dieses Thema es ist fast ein Jahr
lang Krieges scheint kein Frieden kein
Ende in sich zu sein stattdessen könnte
eine nächste Eskalation drohen für mein
Kollege Peter Thiede ist aber klar von
Putin sollten wir uns nicht
einschüchtern lassen ein Thema Peter ja
wenn wir schauen was Wladimir Putin
gerade so macht dann ist das erstaunlich
also er steht Atom U-Boote in die Nähe
von von Norwegen was macht Norwegen
Norwegen warnt was machen wir wir haben
Angst vor Atom u-boten Wladimir Putin
drehte vor einigen Monaten Polen den
ölhandzug holen wollte ohnehin
aussteigen was passiert bei uns wir
haben Angst vor kein Öl mehr also das
was er mir tut die Macht nennt man in
der in der in der Wissenschaft
reflexkontrolle Wladimir Putin weiß
genau welche Ängste in welchem Land
herrschen und also nimmt das kleine
Hämmerchen Haut aus Knie und die
deutschen reagieren wie jedes Bein nach
oben Aufregung ist da meine These wir
nehmen Wladimir Putin der ein
schrecklicher kriechtreiber ist und ein
Bluthund ist und ein wirklicher schwerer
Verbrecher ist wir nehmen ihn aber in
seiner Stärke die ihr demonstriert und
in der Furcht die ihr uns machen will
viel zu ernst es wird Zeit Wladimir
Putin auf seine reale Größe zu
schrumpfen dann machen wir das doch
gleich mal hier schrumpfen wir mal auf
die reale Größe du glaubst also er blöd
nur es ist alles Teil seiner
Propagandamaschinerie du fürchtest keine
weitere Eskalation der Kreml führte über
80 90 Jahren psychologischen Krieg gegen
den Westen wir gehören zum Westen und er
führt ihn natürlich weiter auch nach
1990 mehr putin ist ein Geheimdienst
Mann ist umgeben von Geheimdienst Leuten
in Russland das ist wichtig für das
Verständnis dieses Staates hat die Silo
Viki das sind Geheimdienst Leute und die
Mafia die haben den Staat übernommen das
ist im Prinzip du krempelst den Start
von innen nach außen die Innenseite hat
den Staat dort übernommen und Wladimir
Putin weiß wie das funktioniert und sein
Apparat auch und die machen sich größer
als die tatsächlich sind das Schlimme
ist dass er mir Putin an die scheingröße
selber glaubt hat und wirklich noch
heute glaub er glaubt ja tatsächlich er
könnte die gesamte Ukraine noch besetzen
der stört es ihn auch überhaupt nicht
dass das in seinen generalstabzug sagt
Mensch genauso da bräuchten wir eine
Million Soldaten die haben wir nicht und
die Technik reicht auch nur noch ein
paar Monate die wieder hinten in der
Garage haben aber Wladimir Putin droht
diese Drogen wird nach außen getragen
und erreicht ist halt wenn
Atomwaffen viel eu-boote es sind ja
keine Atom bestücken U-Boot das sind
keine Atomraketen drauf das sind U-Boote
die können diese Raketen tragen die
lässt man dann ins Eis mehr fahren die
lässt man von Norwegen wegen wegen Kreuz
oder schick die mal kurz durch die durch
die Ostsee oder man fliegt mit
atomwaffenfähigen Bomben in die Nähe der
europäischen Grenze oder der NATO drin
Grenzen dann sind das Bomber die könnten
potentiell welche tragen sind als Droge
werdet gemeint
konkrete Vorbereitungen zu werten
sondern als Drohgebärde zu werden aus
seiner Sicht viele hatten natürlich auch
die Befürchtung jetzt ist es um die
Waffenlieferungen ging jetzt werden
weitere Waffen gefordert auch Kampfjets
und da kommt immer wieder ins Argument
oh das könnte zu einer Eskalation kommen
glaubst du dass das eine stringente
Argumentation ist oder glaubst du dass
es quasi nur in diesem Fall geht diesmal
ist es um Bluff aber man muss schon auch
schauen wie die weitere Entwicklung ist
wie siehst du das welche Möglichkeiten
hat denn Vladimir Putin Villa wirklich
jetzt die NATO angreifen Preisfrage
womit da ist nicht mehr viel da und wenn
man dann über Waffen redet die einer
Kriegspartei zur Verfügung gestellt
werden die Rote Armee wäre im Traum
nicht bis Berlin gekommen ohne die
berühmte momentslinie da sind tausende
also mehr als 100.000 Fahrzeuge LKWs
Jeeps tausende von Lokomotiven tausende
von von Eisenbahn Waggons und fast
100.000 Panzer von den USA an Stadien
geliefert worden
berlin ist nicht nur mit russischen
Panzern eingenommen worden sondern
vorwiegend mit amerikanischer Technik
die damals als Kriegshilfe geliefert
worden ist das ist die momentsklinik
kann man nachlesen sind wunderbare
zahlen das ist das berühmte leih- und
übergabegesetz das man in den USA genau
für diese Fälle geschaffen hat also die
Rote Armee hätte es niemals geschafft
und jetzt möchte ich Wladimir Putin mal
und wir hören der der irgendwie sagt ja
wir hätten die Techniker damals nicht
annehmen sollen irgendwie
bei vielen die Angst die Sorge ganz real
jetzt gerade gab es ein friedensmanifest
von der Saga Wagenknecht und Alice
Schwarzer das bringt Peter schon zum
Augenbrauen aber darin wird Julia Neigel
schon gefürchtet dass weitere
Waffenlieferungen quasi in einen dritten
Weltkrieg münden können das steht immer
irgendwie im Raum auch in ist
wahrscheinlich auch zu werden ist Grund
für dieses Manifest ist es etwas was
Ihnen sorge bereitet
also mir macht das
keine Freude solche Diskussionen
überhaupt zu hören oder überhaupt solche
Nachrichten zu lesen weil ich es ganz
wichtig finde so bin ich aufgewachsen
und ich halte es nach wie vor für
relevant und wesentlich dass wir
Friedenspolitik machen der
eskalationspolitik diplomatische
Gespräche anstreben und beide Parteien
versuchen an einem Tisch zu bringen ich
bin nicht dabei ich kenne die die
Konflikte die auch schon vor dem vor dem
Einmarsch von einem von den Russen in
die Ukraine stattgefunden haben nicht es
ist eine ziemlich lange Geschichte
soweit ich weiß ist die schon 2014
losgegangen und hat auch früher und ich
persönlich mag sie mir nicht an wirklich
alle Details zu kennen das heißt ich
kenne die Wahrheit nicht und ich hielt
es für wichtig das ist auch die Aufgabe
meiner Auffassung nach der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland für
Friedenspolitik zu sagen ich halte es
nicht für klug noch Waffen da
reinzuhauen weil es nämlich einfach den
Krieg verlängert und eine
Friedenspolitik noch komplizierter macht
wir sollten eigentlich unsere Aufgabe
erfüllen die nach dem zweiten Welt
Weltkrieg in unserer Hände gelegt worden
ist dass wir eben Friedenspolitik
diplomatische und die eskalationspolitik
betreiben bei militäremotional ist die
Argumentation von Frau neigern natürlich
nachvollziehbar aber wie real politisch
ist sie auch wie sehen Sie das ich nicht
einschätzen ich verstehe beide Argumente
beide Seiten ich bin wirklich
militärisch Projekt aufgewachsen war
acht Jahre bei der Bundeswehr
Fallschirmjäger und Panzergrenadier also
ich weiß um was für Technik ist da geht
ich kenne die ganz genau ich kann das
nicht beurteilen ob die U-Boote mit
Atomwaffen bestückt sind oder nicht das
weiß ich alles nicht aber ich habe
trotzdem Angst ich sag ganz ehrlich ich
bin sehr pro militärisch eingestellt ich
habe trotzdem Angst vor diesem Krieg und
ich sehe momentan ich finde es
vollkommen richtig der Ukraine zu helfen
ganz klar ja auch Waffenlieferung ja bis
zum gewissen Punkt ja aber was folgt
denn wo ist das Ende wo ist die
Diplomatie und da bin ich voll bei ihm
und ich weiß das Argument kommt jetzt
mit Putin kann man nicht reden das hört
jedesmal man muss auch diesen schlechten
Menschen irgendetwas überlegen wie ja
was kommt denn so wir können ja
sagen
wir haben in der Ukraine krieg ja und
den führt einer und es gibt
Verhandlungen die die damals liefen und
die einer aufgegeben hat und das der
Mann heißt
Verhandlungen dabei entschuldigung es
gibt es gab in Weißrussland
fahrverhandlung lesen Sie es nach es gab
Verhandlung in Weißrussland es gab die
in der Türkei die hat Russland verlassen
das ist ja nun wirklich nicht äh ist
kein geheimwerk das ist publik es gab
diese Frage Moment NATO Krieg gegen
Russland nein
die NATO kann kein Krieg führen und zwar
auf einmal einfachen Grund und den bitte
ich einfach schlicht untergreifend auch
an diesen Rändern einmal zur Kenntnis zu
nehmen die NATO ist ein
Verteidigungsbündnis die NATO kann nicht
angreifen das ist nicht möglich nein die
kann nicht angreifen und der Rest ist
Propaganda wirklich und aber aller
schlimmsten aber das kann
das ist auf dem doch das ist Propaganda
das ist schlichte Propaganda da fallen
sie wirklich auf Propaganda rein die
diplomatische Lösung ja dann gehen sie
doch zu Herrn Putin gehen Sie doch mal
auf den Roten Platz und versuchen Sie
ein Schild hochzuhalten wir sind für
eine diplomatische Lösung im Krieg gegen
betreiben sie Moment nein warten sie
reden von der Hose eine ganz einfache
Frage den Bereich in Deutschland befreit
ich ich möchte dass ich die Leute dieser
Wagenknecht und schwarzer Papier
unterschrieben haben mit einem Schild
auf den Roten Platz stellen und fordern
ein Ende und eine diplomatische Lösung
im Krieg gegen die Ukraine wissen Sie
was den passiert die sind keine zwei
Minuten da und dann sind die verhaftet
und ich war vier Wochen lang die ersten
Kriegswochen war ich in Russland ich
habe gesehen wie eine Frau bei so einem
blauen Mantel und eine gelbe Hose
getragen hat von der Straße weg
worden ist ich habe am 23 februar abends
die Invasionsarmee gefilmt wie sie in
die Ukraine reingefahren ist und ich
kenne die eine Ukraine addiert worden
sind und Nein zu sagen wären sie nicht
mal mit zum kurzen Rock in den Park
gegangen hat sich die unter was stellt
man was ist eure Lösung ich denke mal
wissen jetzt die Lösung kann nur sein
dass man die Ukraine so ausstattet dass
sie den dass sie den Krieg auf ihrem
Territorium gewinnen kann oder Wladimir
Putin kommt zu Verhandlung aber wladimir
Putin hat als Bedingung für
Verhandlungen gesetzt dass er die
Ostukraine behalten darf und das kann
doch wohl nicht wahr sein seit wann darf
der der angreift den Frieden diktieren
wann Frieden ist wann der Krieg zu Ende
ist das bestimmt die Ukraine und wenn
ich bin ich auch bei ihnen aber es muss
ja auch in unserem Interesse sein diesen
Krieg wirklich schnell zu beenden wo ich
mich auskenne ich weiß wie viel Weizen
aus dieser aus dieser Region rauskommt
über ein Drittel des weltweiten Weizen
kommt raus gut jeder zehnte Mensch
leidet akut Hunger und wenn Sie je
länger dauert und die Lösung muss doch
irgendwann schnell diplomatische
Lösungen
ausgelöst und das beendet auch keinen
Krieg den Krieg kann nur einer beenden
nämlich der Mann
hingehen
den deutschen sagen wir müssen
für ihr Thema das tut mir leid dass ich
da einmal Ruhe hier in diesem Tisch
bringen müssen hoch emotionale Themen
und ich glaube auch einige Themen bei
dem wir einfach sagen müssen eigentlich
bevor wir keine Zeit mehr haben für ihr
Thema sie haben den weißen angesprochen
sie sie machen sich große Sorgen um die
deutschen Bauern sie sagen wenn das so
weitergeht wird es immer mehr Bauern
geben die werden ihren Hof nicht halten
können Sie Ihre Zeit vielen dank vielen
Dank nach diesen emotional aufgeladenen
Themen wir werden uns sicherlich nachher
noch wieder vertragen und das vermisse
ich heute und wir sind uns sicherlich
alle einig dass wir in Deutschland mehr
Tierwohl wollen mehr Artenschutz wollen
und mehr Standard haben und die hohen
standardwirtschaft setzen die sind auch
gut zu warum der Klimaschutz wir
brauchen mehr Artenschutz und das können
wir leisten das Problem ist nur dass wir
aufgrund von europäischen Auflagen aber
auch von unser Ampel gerade auch in
Özdemir der treibt und so weit dass
jeden Tag 14 Betriebe in Deutschland
unwiederbringlich zu machen wir sind
also dann nicht mehr in der Lage hier
regional CO2 Arm um mit viel Tierwohl
was wir alle wollen Produkte
herzustellen im Gegenteil 2000
Schweinemastbetriebe haben im letzten
Jahr in Deutschland aufgegeben das heißt
die Masse an Ware kommt aus dem Ausland
kommt gerade aus Spanien wo alles
zentral mit
unheimlich hohen CO2 Fußabdruck hierher
wird die Gülle bleibt dort vor Ort
Grundwasserproblematik und so weiter und
das unehrlich an der ganzen Diskussion
ist dass wir mit einem framing
bombardiert werden als Landwirtschaft
das geht los mit einem eckart von
Hirschhausen der in wissen vor acht
steht und sagt unsere Kühe pupsen das
Klima kaputt dann haben Sie hier Herrn
Jänicke gehabt der sagt Landwirte sind
Tierquäler und so weiter und so fort
also keiner von uns hat ein Interesse
daran seine Tiere zu quälen wir denken
in Generationen keiner von uns hat
Interesse das Grundwasser zu verseuchen
es gibt kein bei uns zumindest in
Deutschland kein nitrat-problem wenn ich
Ihnen sage wie das zustande kam ist weil
wir 2012 als Deutschland nicht die
Durchschnittswerte gemeldet haben wie
alle anderen EU-Länder nur die
Höchstwerte und Brüssel hat dann gesagt
macht auch Hausaufgaben sagen sie dass
die deutschen Bauern eigentlich nicht
mehr in der Lage sein können quasi die
Ernährung in Deutschland zu sichern das
machen wir jetzt schon ich wäre aber
Obst und Gemüse haben wir
selbstversorgungskraft von 20 bis 30 %.
das ist lächerlich in Holland sehen wir
was da los ist die Bauern sollen da rein
Weise zu machen wo kommt unser Obst und
Gemüse her das ist doch abenteuerlich
und ich muss auch einen Flug ich muss
auch ein Punkt sagen weil immer oft so
dieses Bio alles muss ja Bio sein also
nachhaltig sein ich bin überzeugt da
konventionell Ackerbauer wir machen seit
Jahrzehnten so gesunde und nachhaltige
Lebensmittel wie es jahrzehntelang nicht
gehabt wir machen preisgünstige
Lebensmittel ist wenig sagen billige
preisgünstige und das wollen wir auch
weiterhin machen das können wir auch
leisten wir können all das was die
Gesellschaft will leisten das ist ein
Gesellschaftsvertrag aber wenn wir nicht
mehr sind und wir sehen es hätte ihr
denkt mit diesen Zahlen nicht aus was
ihr gerade passiert dann sind wir nicht
mehr in der Lage und selbst versorgen
wir wir regen uns auf das sind der
Regenwald abgeholzt wird es kommt aus
aus Brasilien Rinder Weizen Mais Soja
alles was wir hier selber haben und wir
können ja hier das alles machen also
artenschutz ist ein riesen Thema selbst
der Chef vom NABU herr Krüger sagt wir
müssen unser grüner erhalten so das
grüne da halten wir indem wir die Kühe
haben so und die Kühe setzen einen
Anreiz dadurch haben wir Insekten
Vielfalt und diese ganzen
Kulturlandschaft Landschaften die wir
haben die ist ja über Generation
geschaffen wenn wir das aus der Hand
geben steht der Bauer steht das Tor auf
das mein Liebling
zu viel wusste und ich merke auch ich
glaube hier entsteht große Zustimmung
und Frieden gerade in dieser Ecke
geschrieben wurde von Peter völlig bei
ihm wir haben einen organisiertes
sterben also politisch organisiert das
ist zum Teil ist das auch gewollt es
gibt natürlich Missstände auch eine
Landwirtschaft ist auch dort wie wie wie
überall dagegen muss angewandt werden
aber diese die Ausnahmen zur Regel zu
erklären und dann so ein framing zu
betreiben wie es mit dem Bauern passiert
und schauen wir einfach mal in den Osten
da hatten wir da war der Bund der größte
Land eigentlich größte Landeigentümer
mit der bodenverwertungsgesellschaften
nach der Wände und der hat
meistens Ackerland verkauft das führt
dazu dass den Bauern in einer in einer
halben Generation der eigenen Boden
nicht mehr zur Verfügung steht dass sie
mich meistens
Existenz ist zusammen das
Konzerne und zwar den Konzern und ich
bitte mal jeden der in eine Paprika
beißt meiner Südspanien zu fahren und
anzugucken wie eine Wüste und ich mache
da jedes Jahr Urlaub in einer Wüste
Paprika und Orangen angebaut wenn man
das nicht ja also alles mögliche
ja das ist kein Wasser mehr Bauern
kaufen
wenn es mir möglich ist ja oder brauche
ich ein bisschen muss ich hinfahren ist
also jedes Mal Aufwand aber ich schaue
insbesondere gerade beim Gemüse und beim
Obst das ist aus hiesigen regionalen
Gegnern kommt ich bin immer noch der
Auffassung dass es Klima klimatechnisch
völliga Irrsinn ist sich die die keine
Ahnung die Kartoffel aus Peru oder wo
auch immer her zu holen die wird erstmal
hierher verfrachtet also da reden sie
alle sogar davon dass jeder Atma also
jeder jeder Mensch der atmet CO2
Aussehen völlig völlig egal
geschildert hat danke für sie mag äh so
eine Ernährung ganz wichtig sein oder
nach ihrer gesundheitsgeschichte was sie
so hinter sich haben macht sich das bei
ihnen bemerkbar dass sie genau darauf
achten was auf ihrem Teller liegt wissen
Sie vielleicht auch manchmal gar nicht
sie kaufen ein Stück Fleisch und dann
ist das gar nicht kommt gar nicht von
hier sondern hier wird die Produktion
zurückgeschraubt und dann wird das
vielleicht schon woanders aufgekauft
also ich dachte schon darauf wenn es
geht und es geht in aller Regel
nachhaltig
erzeugtes Fleisch zu kaufen was dann
natürlich teuer das ist mir klar aber
dann ist man es eben weniger das muss ja
nicht jeden Tag auf dem Teller sein und
versuche auch dann auf dem
wochenmarktprodukte aus der Umgebung zu
holen sonst müssen wir eine Ernährung
habe ich jetzt noch nicht sehr umstellen
können ich bin ja bis vor wenigen Tagen
noch in der Klinik versorgt worden das
heißt
schnelle Punkte was ich jetzt ändern
muss wir brauchen eine klare und
missverständliche Herkunftskennzeichnung
auch im Sinne des Verbrauchers dass der
Verbraucher ein Produkt hochnehmen kann
sagen hat das jemals Tierwohl soziale
Standard Umweltstandard gesehen dass das
allererste wir müssen mit diesem Bauern
Becken aufhören die Bauern sind bereit
was zu leisten wir haben den letzten 10
Jahren jetzt geschafft 40 % Dünger
einzusparen aufgrund von technischen
Fortschritt alles richtig wir haben
pflanzstein gespart 30 % in 30 in also
in 10 Jahren muss man vorstellen was das
für ein Zeitraum ist da hören sie gar
nichts von ich möchte auch gerne
Landwirtschaftsminister haben der sie
auch immer hinter den Bauern stellt und
sagt lass uns zusammen was erarbeiten
hält sie mir stellt sich hin macht neue
Tierwohl Labels und in diese Tiere leben
sie können Sie unterwandern indem z.B im
Ausland ein Ferkel ohne Betäubung
kastrieren das fällt dann unter ziemlich
Label während jeder das wichtiger Weise
machen müssen dass er vollkommen in
Ordnung aber wir haben keine
Waffengleichheit wir können offen
Weltmarkt nicht bestehen und das müssen
wir wieder herstellen und eine
Wertschöpfung wie gesagt stimmt der
Bauer steht das Dorf wir stellen die
meisten Arbeitsplätze als Landwirte mit
den nachgelagerten Bereich vor der
Autoindustrie und wenn das alles
wegbricht dann haben wir als
Gesellschaft ein massives Problem also
ganz ganz viele Punkte an denen wir ganz
sicher dranbleiben müssen Themen die wir
hier auch weiter in dieser Sendung
diskutieren ich merke es ist überall
Unruhe und es wird wahrscheinlich nach
dieser Sendung noch an vielen Punkten
weiter diskutiert ich möchte mich ganz
herzlich bei dieser lebhaften weil
dieser diskussionsfreudigen und bei
dieser offenen Runde bedanken und ich
möchte mich ganz herzlich bei Ihnen fürs
zuschauen bedanken wann sie es gut bis
bald
[Musik]